it is June 5th 2023 and you're watching
the code report Java is hands down my
all-time favorite programming language
to make fun of python developers roast
it for having so much boilerplate see
developers laugh at absurd class names
like abstract Factory manager Singleton
service manager Factory C plus plus
developers hate that you can't blow your
legs off with memory management as
easily and JavaScript developers are
still trying to fix things like dates
they copied from java over 20 years ago
unfortunately I have some bad news
public static void main string arcs will
no longer be a requirement to write
hello world in Java 21 rendering an
entire industry of java boilerplate
memes static null and void and that's
not good for people like me who make a
living making fun of java because I need
that boilerplate to put food on my
family it's great news however for
anyone who wants to learn Java or more
accurately anyone who's forced to learn
Java this new feature is called unnamed
classes and instant main methods and
allows you to create a main method
without a class and public static void
mainstream arcs this is a great change
but I think we could actually make
things a little bit better by also
removing void and actually why do we
even need a main function in the first
place we could get rid of that
altogether system out seems a little
unnecessary there should just be a
global print line function and if we
rename it to print we then get a perfect
language c-sharp introduced top level
statements in 2020 and maybe in another
10 years Java will get there too before
you get too excited though this feature
is primarily designed to make learning
Java more accessible to beginners the
real boilerplate is not going anywhere
in addition Java is primarily used in
Enterprise which is very slow to adopt
new features there are tons of mission
critical applications out there still
running Java 8 and it could be years or
even decades before these new features
get adopted but Java 21 also has some
other cool updates like structured
concurrency that allows you to run
multiple concurrent jobs on multiple
threads while treating them as a single
unit of work but another thing you might
find kind of crazy about Java is that it
doesn't natively support string
interpolation which means you need to
concatenate a bunch of strings together
like you're in kindergarten or use
string.format which is also kind of
annoying but in Java 21 we have a new
string templates feature which is a new
kind of expression that allows you to
insert values directly into Strings
we've come full circle to where Java is
now looking more like JavaScript and
JavaScript is looking more like Java and
I even noticed that Java recently
updated their website so now it only
looks 10 years out of date instead of
20. this is a big strategic move that
has caused Oracle stock to almost double
over the last year the big question
though is with all these awesome new
features should you learn Java in 2023
when it comes to working as a programmer
you should choose a field that's well
paid interesting and legal but the
reality is that you can only choose two
of these Java is well paid and legal but
not very interesting when looking at the
syntax alone Java is pretty ugly if I
want to write code for the jvm for fun
I'd much rather use a language like
kotlin or Scala that being said Java is
still a Powerhouse language when it
comes to Enterprise software it's used
extensively at companies like Twitter
and Google because it's a very well
balanced language it's performant enough
for most things it's relatively easy to
use and most importantly has a huge
ecosystem of stable libraries and
Frameworks a few days ago I ran a poll
for the best programming language of all
time and Java came in dead last but now
that we no longer need public static
void main string args I think it'll
reclaim the top spot and when with that
being said I'd like to officially
announce my retirement from making fun
of java but let's enjoy these Java memes
together one last time like this one
that explains how object-oriented design
patterns are often unnecessary and
counterproductive when you could just be
using simple variables and functions
this next meme is a good one but you
wouldn't get it so I'm not even going to
try to explain it if you like Windows
you might like Java because it loves to
force you into annoying updates all the
time and as you gain more experience as
a programmer you'll eventually find out
that everything doesn't need to be an
object because these objects will pile
up and devour your RAM and finally it's
important to realize that not every meme
is a joke many of them are a legitimate
cry for help this has been the code
report thanks for watching and I will
see you in the next one